En este video vamos a hablar sobre solubilidad,
que es sólo una forma de describir que también
ciertos solutos pueden disolverse en ciertos
solventes. Como ejemplo podríamos considerar
el cloruro de sodio y pensar por qué se
disuelve bien en agua. Bueno para hacer
eso sólo tenemos que recordar lo que hace el
agua cuando no tiene nada disuelto en ella,
de modo que cuando no hay nada disuelto en agua
tenemos 1 oxígeno unido a 2 hidrógenos. Este
extremo, del que hemos hablado en otros videos, es
parcialmente negativo, porque a los electrones les
gusta pasar más tiempo alrededor del oxígeno; este
es parcialmente positivo -parcialmente positivo- y
vemos que se forma un enlace de hidrógeno, donde
el extremo parcialmente negativo de una molécula
de agua es atraído por el extremo parcialmente
positivo de otra molécula de agua. De eso se
tratan los enlaces de hidrógeno; tenemos videos
completos sobre eso, en realidad muchos videos
sobre el tema. La razón por la que el cloruro de
sodio se disuelve bien en agua se debe a que el
cloruro de sodio como compuesto iónico puede
disociarse en sus iones constituyentes:
en 1 catión sodio y 1 anión cloruro. Hemos visto
esto antes, así que este es el anión cloruro, esto
de aquí es 1 catión sodio. La razón por la que
se disuelve bien es que la carga negativa puede
ser atraída al extremo positivo de las moléculas
de agua, es decir, al extremo del hidrógeno, y el
catión sodio es atraído al extremo negativo de las
moléculas de agua. Entonces, lo que realmente está
sucediendo es que la atracción entre los iones
y las moléculas de agua es más fuerte que la
atracción de los iones entre sí y que la atracción
entre las propias moléculas de agua. Así que las
moléculas de agua no se agrupan y dicen "No
queremos tener nada que ver con ustedes sodio y
cloruro"; dicen: "Ey, también nos atraen un poco,
así que ¿por qué no nos mezclamos?" Podemos ver
cosas que tienen fuerzas de atracción menores,
tal vez en las que la fuerza principal son sólo
fuerzas de dispersión. Si piensas en una tina de
pentano tiene fuerzas débiles como para atraerse
el uno al otro, y luego, si piensas en una tina
de hexano, hay una especie de fuerzas débiles.
Pero si pusiéramos un poco de pentano -llamemos a
este el soluto-, si lo pusiéramos en un solvente
de hexano se disolvería, porque se atraen entre
sí tanto como se atraen a sí mismos. Ahora,
¿qué crees que va a pasar si tratamos de poner,
digamos, algo de hexano, si lo vemos como un
soluto en agua? Bueno en esta situación el agua
va a estar mucho más atraída a sí misma que al
hexano. Digamos que esta es el agua. Vamos a
tener estos globos de forma de hidrocarburo
porque el agua será más atraída a sí misma; no
es fácil que el hidrocarburo se disuelva. Ahora,
hay muchas moléculas orgánicas que se disuelven
bien y eso suele suceder porque una parte de la
molécula tiene cierta polaridad. Un ejemplo es el
etanol, que tiene un grupo OH; el etanol tiene una
cadena de 2 carbonos. Cuando hablamos de alcohol
en lenguaje cotidiano, de beber alcohol, hablamos
de etanol. Hay muchos otros anales, muchos otros
alcoholes, pero esto es etanol. Si mezcláramos
alcohol en agua se disolvería bien, y eso sucede
porque este oxígeno de aquí es más electronegativo
que las cosas a las que está enlazado, y
así todavía acapara un poco los electrones,
todavía tiene esa carga parcialmente negativa,
todavía tenemos esa polaridad en la molécula,
entonces es capaz de atraer a las moléculas de
agua vecinas, lo que permite que se disuelva. Pero
podríamos imaginar que si tuviéramos un alcohol
con una cadena de carbono mucho más larga, digamos
que tuviera 10 carbonos o 15 carbonos, de repente
la proporción relativa a qué tanta polaridad tiene
comparada con qué tan grande es la molécula
hará cada vez más difícil que se disuelva en
un solvente polar como el agua. Entonces nuestra
gran conclusión es que lo similar se disuelve.